a reject nation it's Greggy
Johnny we're gonna watch Cobra Kai
episode six quiver for those few who
highly demand that we keep watching it
even though most definitely don't watch
these this is just for you few who
harassed just as a heads-up we do
full-length TV show reactions watch
alongs
on our patreon page one of the main
things we do over there I cover attack
on Titan almost done a season one of
that almost done was season forward the
flash started Gotham a few episodes and
John covers Riverdale is on season two
he's caught up today with a Lana Full
Metal Alchemist Brotherhood together we
are covering full-length Roger longs for
Cobra Kai black lightning one more
episode to go Jessica Jones season 2 a
few more to go we finished season 1 in
my hero academia we're hopping on a
season to go check out our patreon and
speaking of patreon patron today shout
out for a certain special somebody in a
Raj Krishna garage we don't know you as
personally as I wish we could I know we
primarily just stick to talking about
films and I feel like you kind of like
it that way but I would like you to open
up a little bit more so I thought to get
to know you better I want her to look up
what your last name is your heritage
from what I found here it means black
dark and Sanskrit this is the name of a
Hindu God believed to be an incarnation
of the god Vishnu he was the youngest of
King vasudeva's eight children six of
whom were killed by King Kamsa because
of a prophecy that a child of Vasudeva
would kill comes I know what all of that
means because I follow the Hindu
religion very much so I am honored to
know you because you seem like you come
from a very important lineage and
knowing such history behind your name
now I know why you don't like to get too
personal because you have some secrets
to keep buddy totally get it I just
recommend you change your last name if
you don't want people coming after you
who are enemies of I don't know I'm just
thinking
the movie The Mummy now imagining like
skeletons attacking you
yeah I've been very Raj deals with
religious yeah okay interesting Boston
star-lord you to get these eight cards
in the shot outlook like the 70-day
quiver
there's also a place where you keep
arrows you have aged terribly since you
were a little kid man moisturize dog
full circle right on his back - Miguel
stole a white belt yeah that's advanced
I want an action figure that does that
damn boy guys here I know it sucks first
I need to see where you're at
everybody's all in you're just noticing
that no he's back yeah
I wonder if Ralph Macchio is like kept
this up over the years I doubt it hey oh
there's gonna be some bullying was a
sweaty pointless beggar I didn't know
we're coming to the dojo with me let's
try to remember what happened ten years
ago and you and I hit the mat for a
little karate what that's some sparring
for you they had a fat kid they know
that time they take in
[Music]
those are jeans did you guys hear that
lip
you can't hold someone make it funny you
how are you gonna handle an elbow to the
chief by calling the PO what he does
realize the Nazis lost the war right
it's not like he can actually hurts do
it yeah it's gonna destroy this case I
got got my ass kicked my money [ __ ] the
other way Tyler man Erman do a little
karate with you interested he asking me
as a friend or as my boss as a friend
I'm busy because she gives [ __ ] I
did because I ordered the little creep
you gonna punch your boss you gotta make
a tight fist I'm around the outside
underneath squeeze the knuckles extend
the hands straight out you see that hey
come on I'm gonna head back inside and
announced the sorry you almost got
killed sales event oh he's got a new dad
yeah he's gonna probably having him do
karate with him and then they're gonna
go play catch
are you thank you for sex this tract
opens up an umbilical cord nobody else
did
where's that blow pop there's a nice
round house I guess I should be taking
lessons from you that was a freebie
they're flirting Oh young love I just
wasted a relationship that becomes an
argument yeah Oh sweetie I want to see
okay let's write you this [ __ ] down
because a murderous miguel dr. Shay
could be on the spectrum
good I don't know what that is but get
off it pronto all right if you don't
want me to call you lip that don't have
a weird lip can't you get surgery for
that please change the topic you don't
think I want to it's tough when it's
right in front of me if you want to be
something other than a nerd with a
skarner's liver you got to flip the
script okay
I get a face tattoo or gouge your eye
out I'll call you back
right no don't do that one you'll still
look like a freak oh man this is you
don't know what it's like to be us see
you tomorrow
so me I know oh yay Oh Robbie Larusso
send me go that photo of all those
sausages oh he must have a new iPhone
versus having a Dazzler I know
Oh Boston when his mom left him before
he went off in his face rustles don't
you get in enough fights already at
school doing it at outer British social
rejects he doesn't have a single friend
so you want to be the next Bruce Lee huh
so that's why Johnny is a dick that's
upbringing he was a nerd he did know
what it was like to be a loser huh and
he's just so afraid of acknowledging
that place because it's too traumatic
he's gonna go into it he's all on her
back technically breaking her
it's like Oh Robbie and you since that I
was here this is good stuff very
important that one's on you pal
next time you outsmart the dope I think
is that how do you were doing where is
the punching that's the foundation of my
karate that's cool so you want to stick
around learn a few things sure there's
nothing my dad would hate more some of
you I've hit please don't apologize
because I was you
oh here we go cool I used to have no
friends so still there used to be the
weirdo kid I'm not that weird I still
hooked up with babes and all but today
it's like a Cobra I had to shed my
looser skin find my true power
and you guys will too deserves every
knob I'm flipping the scripts damn
wait you the kid with the lip nice cut
bro yeah all that matters is that you
become badass [ __ ] yeah Pauly
yet that was fun for him
J does not exist in this dojo does it no
sensei
defeat does not exist in this dojo
doesn't no sensei unless we're sparring
and then 50%
class are you ready to learn the way the
fist
[Music]
no great now we know Miguel's in the
next episode this is probably the only
episode I've ever enjoyed of this Robbie
kid yeah yeah I can't say I liked him in
anything any other up in like probably
pinpoint a moment or two this is one
where I'm like I liked him from
beginning to anitha's performance was
very naturalistic I thought the
situation's he was put in give you a
chance to sympathize for him and give
him that misunderstood territory and I
think the progression of how he's
getting closer to Danny is somewhat
predictable but it feels natural it
doesn't you know like you know he's
skeeving his way in or manipulating his
way up the ladder his heart seems
genuinely interested in who Danny is now
to start off in a manipulation tactic
but it seems like he really is starting
to view him it headed out a path of
naturally leaving him like a father
figure
yeah one I think it helps to to have the
other guys working with the dealership
kind of pranking him and petting him and
stuff because it does make him a bit
more sympathetic because you do actually
watch him get duped twice yeah yeah and
that does something to that character
and yeah that was one of the biggest
impressions this episode left on me
actually was this is hands-down the best
Robbie episode and I feel like they've
found did they maybe didn't have a
direction for that character previously
but I feel like that character has found
a solid direction now yeah definitely
and yeah I definitely enjoyed watching
him a lot more than in previous episodes
him and then I mean just the class were
the two like biggest takeaways for me
from this episode yeah I thought Johnny
Lawrence had a really good art because I
thought it was gonna be something where
he comes back he apologizes and he
really owns up but he instead on used it
to identify which I thought was really
neat he didn't say I'm sorry he admitted
to what he did but he also said like I
used to be you and he explained his
motivation for why he's doing what he's
doing that would flip walking in there
at the mohawk that was really clever I
didn't recognize him at first you make
me say like I had to go oh that's who it
is I thought that was a nice visual cue
for his teachings are working even
improving his lifestyle because Hawkeye
just looks a lot more confident now -
you walked in with a whole new
or yeah yeah it's like Johnny's methods
they're arguable but you can see how
that kid took it to heart and made it
work
yeah in a way that yeah it's kind of
interesting and I appreciate a lot that
they have let the character of Johnny
Lawrence be such that sometimes you just
flat out disagree with it early on in
the episode you'll think you're taking
this too far man you're being a dick I
like that they just let him do that and
then you know Miguel talks to him later
and you can sort of see the arc unfold I
feel like a lot of other shows might
tone it down with him and make him like
flirt with the wine but not necessarily
cross him I feel like here you know
there are still parts of his character
that are challenging and I think that's
part of what's so great about this show
I feel like he should have gotten an
Emmy nomination for this show I don't
know if YouTube red is in the spectrum
of like that's real television it's real
at this point if you're nominating like
Netflix and Hulu and Amazon shows I
think YouTube absolutely consideration
hour long I think for it multiple angles
for a comedy show for her comedic
performance I haven't seen some of the
other nominees I think he gives a very
layered performance and it's something
that has a lot of traumatic depth to it
without ever veering too far into the
serious territory where what he's being
a dick it's like you could always sense
that a lot of where the humor comes from
is a place of pain that's what makes you
sympathize and like him so I think his
performance is easily the best of any
one on this show he's the best written
character out of anyone on the show yeah
I hope he gets more recognition because
I'm sure when everyone got excited for
this it was a return of Roth Macchio but
he is obviously like the real highlight
of this show now pretty soon we're gonna
see William Zabka popping up in every
movie yeah I mean I feel like he has a
perfectly pitched performance for what
this show is because he does fully
embody that you know kind of macho dude
that he fancies himself to be but also
he when you have more serious or
slightly more weighty moments he's
really believed like he's surprisingly
believable yeah in those and then even
the funny stuff like when he's just
doing his Johnny Lawrence thing and it's
you know played for humor I've never
seen a moment from him on this show
that's fallen flat sure and even the
flashback I thought worked pretty well
both at the beginning of the episode
where he finds the karate class and
later on when you see ended or
he meant over dinner it was good visual
storytelling to let us know he was these
guys as opposed to him just showing up
to the class and saying yeah from ago so
you don't know what it's like to be us
and then you see that know he was that
yeah yeah and and that highlights a very
real thing that just some people are
that when they're growing up and they
just veer completely to the opposite of
the spectrum and that's a thing that can
happen also you know it would make it so
that you never know and you can see that
trickle down into into Robbie to you
know which is part of like a further
justification I feel like for that
characters you can kind of see now cuz
you have like a little bit of glimpse
into what a Johnny's father was like and
then you know Johnny and now you see
Robbie and yeah I kind of tell the stuff
the romance me Miguel and the Rousseau
kid great I think it's great week I
really buy it I was roofer it since day
one and I think their chemistry is solid
I like that touch where she was kind of
telling him some tips on how to improve
his like work I thought that was really
cool really cool stuff well yeah we
seems like she could have defended
herself and when Kyler walks up our way
through it just turns right back around
it was a [ __ ] little [ __ ] I got I got
told alright guys well this is a there's
another really good episode man I'm I I
kind of wish season two was out already
so I can know that we're not gonna reach
a conclusion soon just keep going I
really loved watching the best way to
end the week with these ones all right
Jack nation well thanks for tuning in
full-length TV show reactions are on our
patreon music video coverage weekly Q&A
s as well love to have you become a
patron ejected a meantime you can
subscribe click the notification bell
catch you guys soon